good morning how you doing welcome back
to another episode of oxygen not
included everything is awful we are
dying everyone is going insane this is
overheated whatever that is I don't even
know what that is but maybe because it's
next to a literal volcano that might
explain why we are all about to die so
what I need to do eventually after I
solve the food crisis which couldn't
possibly be solved too early it could
not be solved too early well once I get
that all organized we do something to
fix what is happening here I I'm just
doing this because I realize it's just a
little too low for my taste
uh what I need to do eventually after I
do that is I need to get the insulated
tile now I don't know if insulated tile
ah it's right there good insulated tile
I need to get that so I can create a
nice floor underneath so that things
don't go horribly awry but that is next
step cuz if there's a name for this
title it is sweating bullets because I
am sweating bullets there is just no way
in hell that I'm ever gonna be able to
live through this if this heat oh my god
oh my god
even the abyss alight is hot abyssal I
disposed not really allow heat to
transfer it's over heat temperatures do
it melting by at 3:40 it's fine because
so long as we can get the food going
then we should be able to do what we
need to do to survive and we will
literally do whatever it takes to
survive even though we probably aren't
making enough oxygen which is why I'm
making this so that we can kind of get
ahead of the curve here because if we
can and I will do whatever it takes to
make sure that we survive and I'm
putting this here so that I can get
better access to water because I know
that people are running around a lot for
water but
that's not a good start but if we have
water accessible from both sides then
that should alleviate a lot of the
problem and allow us to better
facilitate the distribution of water
throughout mine base so long as we are
good there we will be good everywhere I
know we'll give these guys a little
boost that they need and I know it's not
efficient the way that I got the boost
distributed but I don't care because
like I've said many times prior I care
more about aesthetics than I do about
efficiency even though we are dying
I still have standards even in crisis
ease I still have standards so with that
being said I will survive I'm actually
gonna get rid of this here so that we
can have the food be delivered up here I
know it's not ideal to be eating dirt I
get that it is definitely not ideal to
be eating dirt but given the
alternatives we don't have much of a
choice we're running out of Wawa running
bigge out of Wawa I hate that I said
those words okay looks like someone
chopped off the power which is good I
don't know why that has stopped probably
because it's the end of day yep it's the
end of day so what I need I need to
focus there's a lot of things that are
just out and about I need to pare down
the urgency on some of these things so
that people are more understanding of
what actually is problem and what is not
a problem we're not doing great on food
but we're doing ok on food and I need to
prioritize the things that must be done
sooner rather than later which is these
things the food needs to be at a 6 this
needs to be at a 7 just across here so
that we can get to there we need to put
a new water pump right here is maybe the
here-ish yeah let's so what I'm gonna
need to do is I'm going to need to
create a new set of ladders down here
for now and then make new pumps here and
there which means now that there's
access on oh but I don't want to do that
just yet because I don't want to lose
access to this but I can get rid of that
because
people who can at least go around that
people are doing that that's good that's
good all good there
why is there no oxygen over here or
these not pumping up but that's okay one
crisis at a time this will be good
because this is there's a lot of oxygen
flowing up from this area so this is
gonna complementary flow of oxygen from
the other way how we do an analogy we're
doing good on algae because these are
now more efficient I've always thought
that like these should be more efficient
they should they use a smaller amount of
algae they use a lot of water so but
it's a trade-off because it's about if
it's about like recycling it should be
more efficient than just burning the
oxygen like it definitely should be much
much more efficient so it is so that's
good they don't even produce heat this
produces heat these don't even produce
heat because it's just nice smooth now
the only problem is we got to set up
some sort of a water recycling system
which we are nowhere near doing yet
because we are not even oh no oh no okay
um maybe having to those is not the best
idea in the world
gee okay but that's been done out we can
pour it the we don't even need a the
were there really that would just slow
things down okay so now that that's been
done we can put this new pump right
there we can destroy these we can put
this pump there once that gets destroyed
and then that's at the new water line
and then they can get it from either
side and then I don't have to worry
about referring one to the other we can
have multiple ones there and that'll be
so Gucci so now we just need to worry
about the food how we're good we're ok
the food let's just say the food is
doing better than it was so now we can
worry about temperature modulation which
is the next step that we need to do
because the temperature is only gonna
get hotter it's already penetrated at
this point and the other point around it
is getting hotter this is a serious
problem I cannot overstate how quickly
overheating will kill us
it just does and it's so fast and it
sneaks up out of nowhere so I want to
cut it I've had games where I just like
oh god the heat and then it's just a
nightmare of epic proportions there's a
lot of stuff buried in here I'm thinking
that there might be some goodies in here
that I'm gonna want so I'm gonna go
ahead and tell people to just go ahead
dig all of that out let's not dig into
the bedrock because that's naturally
insulative that'll be good they'll be
working on that we got these going we
got the water going good that's still
not destroyed yet but it's the end of
the day I know I'm aware I'm aware of
our food shortage I'm aware of that I
know and I know that no one likes the
food that we have any hey but hey looks
like the people who were sick
stop getting sick ha ha hee who's a
little stress but only 1% you entitled
piece of crap he who you entitled piece
of [ __ ] who your way to dream bill hey
why are you hurt
why are you hurt we'll go to the
bathroom in oh [ __ ] literally oh [ __ ]
whatever you do you could you please do
not poop on the floor it's fine it's
fine
database cycle update as far as we can
tell we are hundreds of miles beneath
the surface of the planet digging our
way out will take some time
my duplicants will survive but they are
not meant for sustained underground
living under what possible circumstances
could my pod have ended up here
right I have learned that no matter what
everyone except for you catch you as far
as I know was able to hold their bladder
I don't know why the outhouse has never
got unplumbed but they did and that's
fine I guess
it's not good but it's okay what do you
have for me blossom seed I guess maybe I
cannot take another person because I
just can't deal with the food
requirement so I'll take blossom seed I
guess even though the irrigation is not
having anything it's all good
we finished our research noe we still
need know we have not finished our
research at all also totally fine
all of this 100% fine there is no reason
to be nervous because nothing is wrong
all is as it should be
I didn't realize how often these needed
emptying I didn't even know they needed
emptying in the first place but that's
okay oh oh we don't need you to be an
artist because artist is not why we're
here
you're gonna be the scientist you're
gonna be a scientist okay Wow boy
alright that's what I'm talking about
right there that is that is what I'm
talking about
Wow Wow okay this is good this is good
this is all good you can choose still
hurting but I think you'll get better in
time okay maybe maybe we're not gonna
die maybe we're not gonna die after all
maybe what's really gonna happen is
we're not gonna die and what I realized
now is beer dude doesn't need to
necessarily be an electrical engineer
even though he's got that you know he
looks like a farmer maybe tinkle tinkle
Tish
no one's interested in farming I could
get more people I could I don't really
think I want to more people would be
good because then I would get more power
and then I would be able to make more
mush and then I would be able to make
more research and then I'll be able to
do the things that I need to do so
technically speaking it would be good to
have that how is in the ever
I'd like the dam it's like a crux of
thing I guess it'd be okay
I suppose that it might be actually okay
and then we'd have more people to do the
expunging thing whatever they're doing
there and then they would be able to do
what they do I'm not on a percent sure
I'm actually gonna destroy that for now
I don't think we need two of those
I think technically if we had someone
that was cook we could get more people I
think I'm pretty sure you also want to
be strong so maybe I could also give you
that that's that seems good you you can
have more than one we can have
duplicates that do more than one thing
we're uh we're back oh you're big now I
don't know what you're eating
are you eating uh I guess maybe you are
eating something okay good great good
good to see you hey good good you're not
putting slime out are you yeah you do
put out slime why are we suffering your
existence kill it here let's meet
yes yes yes yes the answer was in front
of my face all along it was right in
front of my face all along it was
farting right in my face all along how
are we doing on the research front we're
making progress but we're not making a
lot of progress I mean there's only one
person that's able to research that much
and that's he who and who he who ain't
doing it I don't know that's met the
coal is melting no oh my god the coal is
melting is it gonna turn into oil or
something what happens when coal melts
is it turn to oil Oh God the copper is
gonna melt alright okay um oh let's get
rid of this one down here cuz we don't
need that down then anymore we're gonna
make that's the science room
the poop stalls are doing okay i i'm
just hesitant to make anyone build
anything more because we're barely
sustaining as it is right now i just
need to wait on the research happening
because if the research happens then
we're actually gonna make the insulation
that's gonna happen so that we can
prevent ourselves from being swamped by
eating okay let me look at the summary
real quick here we're just barely
meeting our oxygen requirements which is
good if we get in another duplicate in
here we will ruin that average travel
time is way too far but you know what
can you do the place got bigger okay why
are these subs why has no one getting
them any water
no one's getting them anymore and we are
running out of water very quickly oh
distillation okay that's great whatever
let's finish up though what we got and
we'll worry about everything else later
because right now we can't worry about
it there's a lot of things that need to
be done still there's a lot of power
generation that needs to be done we're
still barely keeping up with this I
don't know why we're barely keeping up
with it but we are barely keeping up
with it so I'm gonna let things run I'll
be right back
and then hopefully everything's not
awful by the time I get back we dead
we're not dead okay we're not dead
that's good okay we're not dead but we
have someone that is available for
printing suit-wearing okay Rowan's
pretty cool
April babyface alright evil baby vase
you are kind of babyface and I bet
you're evil I bet i buy just bed okay
evil babyface this may be the worst
thing I've ever done but here we are and
this is the end times
definitely so evil babyface I don't know
what you're gonna be doing but and
you're sleeping in the middle of nowhere
but whatever umm evil babyface okay so
that's one more person that we gotta
feed which means that we need to make a
little bit more food but if evil
babyface can pull his goddamn weight
then evil babyface is gonna be okay okay
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say
that this is baseline this this line
right here off of this and I'm actually
gonna we're actually gonna get rid of
these down here cuz they're too far down
anyway and we are gonna make this the
baseline right here so this is gonna be
the baseline which means that nothing is
going to be above
nor below that line led we're all on the
same page then my research finally
finished why is no one doing super
computer research super computer
researching trick what do you mean super
computer researching treat you can do
super compete you see who you need to be
the researcher okay I got a give evil
baby's face you're gonna be the farmer
look at this farm if everywhere there
was a good old farm boy evil baby face
which is very weird evil baby face you
are the farmer okay
so evil baby face you gonna do farming
okay you're you're the farm you're just
a good ol farm boy with evil bland evil
baby face is gonna poison our food
supply by the way I have a funny feeling
about that but that's just what evil
baby face do maybe I should set the
priorities yeah your priority is that
okay priority let me just give people
the priority that they obviously have
specialty for you need researching
because that's what you're for that is
what you do do you have any priorities
Turner no but it sure shit's gonna be
supply and storing an evil baby face
sure is farming okay so now that I
actually am smart and I actually gave
people priorities which I don't know why
I didn't do that I haven't I've been
staring at this and then turns out I was
dumb Hey look our food is growing our
crops are growing my skin is clearing up
my eyes are sparkling my teeth are
gleaming my nose hairs are what
everything's good okay good this is
great everything we're fine now we're
happy I'm happy
who's researching nobody but that's okay
apparently why is nobody love of God
this grace reasons why you need research
stomach how's the temperature doing
okay let's make it uh I think that a
nine priority huh you go oh my god what
is wrong with you you're not doing it I
swear you who skilled up who did that
who did that great good for you
skills to pay the bill you could you I
am proud of you you're gonna be real
good at digging you are so good at
digging I can I appreciate you look at
that that's a keen hat right there I'm
sorry it's just sore back you have a bed
evil baby face youyou have a bed I know
that you're good oh yeah I know you're a
good old farm boy why are you sleeping
in the mess hall that's a little strange
what the hell is this overlay what what
is this it's all fine because I'm not
actually worried about it everything is
good we got insufficient oxygen
generation but only barely like barely
insufficient oxygen generation this is
actually good I mean shockingly things
are looking okay yes he who thank you he
who thank you he who thank you very much
he who in the meantime I don't think I
can wait around for this I don't know
what what's the insulating properties of
like just tile specific heat capacity
thermal conductivity I don't know if
that's better or worse well conductivity
is four point five two point nine so
technically it's better than metal but I
don't know if it's better than yeah I
guess it's better than that since I
can't wait around for
them to just decide to fix it I'm just
gonna go ahead and fix it I'm actually
gonna make the layer below it the line
actually mmm I'm gonna make I'm gonna
make it one more below just because I'm
gonna make it extra thick it's gonna be
the thickest thing and then it'll go
right to there what's the what's the
thermal capacity of this so technically
speaking I think tieless no it's the
same as sandstone I guess that makes
sense because it is basically sandstone
so I'm gonna make anything that's not
sandstone be the replacement for that
and then I'm gonna make tile fill in the
rest of the gaps just for now just had
to scream good job evil baby face you
got this holy crap we are doing good
holy crap we got twenty seven thousand
that's really good really happy I'm
really quite happy with that that is
really good Wow okay you know things
were looking real bad there for a little
bit but now things are looking pretty
okay I can't believe I'm saying it but
things are God things are might be
looking up things might be looking up
guys he who's doing research crops were
growing you know I think actually we
could we could probably we could
probably you know maybe we could maybe
we could do this up nice maybe we could
have like a thing with farm tiles in it
I'd be pretty cool right let's not get
ahead of ourselves let's I gotta
remember my ambition sometimes it
exceeds my ability to do anything does
it make planter BOTS planter boxes are
good I like planter boxes planter boxes
yeah evil baby face you don't have a
home yeah comfy bed did you have a comfy
bed somewhere that I didn't know about
evil baby face I don't like that I have
to say your name is evil baby face every
time Oh air is not strong up there why
is there not strong up there
I do not know maybe I should put this up
there now but I don't want to chew
through all my oh you're 2.2 22.9 that's
a lot I'm not gonna fall into the trap I
think it's a trap to use that and I
think the better way of doing it this is
genius I'm a genius oh I'm real smart I
know the better way of doing it why
would I not have this go all the way up
in one side then I could have ladder and
then when I get the fire pole I have the
fire pole and the ladder and then
everything will be hunky-dory Barberie
corn whoa that's that's intense can be
harvested for lumber why didn't need
lumber okay well I don't have those but
I'll worry about that later what I do
have is meal wood and then I can copy
these Rob I am
oh that looks grand except I'm gonna
cancel these blossom plant it and copy
that to there get some nice variety in
our diets boom boom boom boom get some
power up in there hey you know guys I
was panicking just a little bit ago but
frankly things are looking up things are
looking up guys
things were looking real up you know we
don't even need this setup priority
anymore we've got a good amount of food
we've got a surprisingly good amount of
food oh wait no I found a big storm uh
curry midnight well either way we got a
surprising amount of food and then our
problem is solve for all eternity for
all these need to be emptied very sooner
we're gonna have a pooping problem yeah
give that a nice squish dookie squish it
up oh people babyface has food poisoning
okay so now that this is there what I'm
gonna do and this is so smart of me
we're gonna put
three four five damn you you
inconsistent layout why did I curse
myself by not doing this properly I
don't know why that's gonna bother me
but on the other side I could do it I
can do it on the other side and I know
it's really asinine of me to do this and
flip-flop what I just did but I could do
it way no 1 2 3 4 5 there 1 2 3 4 5
god damn it damn it damn yeah damn it
why did I have to build these so
stupidly damn you ok whatever we're just
gonna put him in further doors that's
it's fine fine it looks weird but it's
fine can't cancel put it in front of the
doors it's fine looks dumb but now what
we got is if we've got 2 going up one
way I can get rid of these I can have
lights which are nice every which way it
looks dumb it looks so dumb it looks so
dumb so dumb it's good it's a thing of
beauty
ok hey and we got something else here
directly a case and I likes and everyone
loves sand making it summed rechlicz
now they only graze on meal would plan
to screw that I guess I could that's not
too hard ah sure we'll do some direct
let's I don't know what I'm gonna be
able to get the the ranching stuff all
good and going but hopefully at some
point all right we're doing ok I can
hardly believe it
but we're doing relatively ok did we
finish we finished the research we did
two insulated tile oh ok slow heating oh
that's even better igneous rock I don't
have enough to make it but hey that
would be cool if I could do that now
what I can do is I can make this all out
of that insulated tile all the way to
there dig all of this out and make it
all insulated tile and that's the new
objective and then build another layer
of it after that I don't know how
insulated this could be it's not very
insolent made out of metal
ok so that's so that's a bit of a weak
point but even so this is
good it's not perfect but it's pretty
good and then I can put a few more of
these here and there wherever and that
should be able to actually be pretty
good that that honestly is it should be
pretty good well we got to do next for
research and what I'm gonna do for next
time because I gotta end this episode
I'm out of time because we're gonna get
the not that we're gonna get the
filtration stuff so we're gonna get
filtration next also I got to build them
showers but I got to worry about getting
clean water going before I worry about
cars so I'm gonna end this for now thank
you everybody so much for watching we
have got quite a bit ahead of us but
that does not mean that we are going to
shirk from our duties our duties are
unsure Keable so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
[Music]